this used to be a flourishing mining
town but now mining machinery is sitting
unused on by the road
idelle who so grew up in car to her
father was a miner and she still
remembers the good old days she works
for the trade union solidarity and is
often a bearer of bad news since June
last year I've handled more than 6000
retrenchments iron always been the
hardest hit of all the community
commodities the price of iron ore has
plunged by more than 75 percent since
its peak five years ago the drop is
mainly due to fall in the mountain china
major blow for KATUSA economy his whole
town has been built upon the iron ore
mines so the impact is huge the
insecurity has forced locals to tighten
their belts shops are closing house
prices have tanked and businesses that
rely on the mind like this construction
company heart packing up shop and scenes
like this are playing out in mining
communities throughout the country the
two is a microcosm of what's happening
to commodity based economies around the
world it really is a boom or bust
situation way in the good times the
economy grows money's generated people
employed and NASA need it's downturn
people are leaving Coutu
everyone at this union meeting is
worried about the job cuts
nobody knows [ __ ] who will get fired
this leads to despair and anger Italy we
don't know if this is going to happen
we're left in the dark
we want to know please be patient
I know it's hard and I understand your
emotions the members of Massage Union
all speak Afrikaans and I'm mainly white
was a baby Davidson Anna works for in um
biggest mine Union he is very worried
about his workers families he one
employee in the mind represent a huge
family of people so 4,000 people to be
retrench that simply means 40,000 people
out of the number of people who are
working at the mine will be affected by
this process so far
with an unemployment rate already
topping 25% South Africa can only hope
that commodity prices will recover soon